[Musique]
j'ai commencé les courses pour garder la
forme j'avais je n'avais plus assez de
temps pour m'investir dans le club
notamment un club de sport de sports
collectifs donc il a fallu que je trouve
un sport individuel et la course à pied
donc ça m'a permis effectivement de deux
mariés mon emploi du temps de sportifs
avec monopoly temps professionnel donc
la course était vraiment par praticité
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir c'est le rêve de
d'ultra trailer que je me suis mis dans
la tête en 2011 et notamment sa a été
donc ça a été calme quelques années
après donc en 2015 m finisher de mon
premier trail du mont blanc
c'est quelque chose qui me fait rêver
donc j'ai réussi à passer ce cap là une
première fois en 2015 en 2017 et je vais
reproduire ça ans je l'espère en
dominant
les futurs objectifs c'est déjà terminé
mon treizième eco drive et puis pourquoi
pas pleins d'autres par la suite les
pilot qu'à court terme en 2020 donc je
sais que je vais participer au prochain
ultra trail du mont blanc est une
nouvelle fois cessé d'améliorer un petit
peu mon mon chrono de 35 heures pour
faire le tour le tour du mont-blanc et
après beaucoup de courses encore qu'ils
peuvent me faire rêver tant que mon
corps me permettra de les faire